[Musik]
das musste jetzt herzukommen sollte
folglich wieder eingeschaltet habe ich
habe für euch und für uns heute in der
bibliothek der absoluten hilft mir
klassiker weiter gebraucht und ein
seltenes juwel gefunden diese folge ist
für mich ganz besonders dann ist es die
folge hashtag köln war bus wer ist der
größte babo der stadt und wie ihr
vielleicht wisst wo nicht auch in köln
also bin ich sehr gespannt wie diese
lokalen gangster so aussehen was die so
machen was ist jedenfalls sagen kann ist
dass ich weiß dass es zu der folge schon
ein paar andere nations cup unter einem
von luca kommt oft da habe ich mit
meiner beschreibung folgen könnt ihr
auch abdecken um da mal eine andere
sicht der dinge zu sehen also dass leute
wie immer macht euch bereit dafür dass
eure gehirnzellen jetzt aggressiv
frittiert werden
wir starten denn das video rein also wir
sehen schon mal die stadt köln wird in
angst und schrecken versetzt ja soviel
kann man schon mal sagen also die kölner
es heißt nicht ohne grund köln bus oder
der 1 in köln war wurde ihm jetzt hier
sehen ich denke man kann man zu dieser
gruppe dazu zählt denn er schießt
feuerwerk ich fühle dich
streitgegenstand
[Musik]
heute stellen wir vor
was muss man den kopf von einer person
vorgehen dass sie sie auf einem hausdach
begibt 3 silvesterraketen ist wieso bist
ein tischfeuerwerk absolut und sich dann
denkt so ja die stadt gehört mir keiner
kann was machen
kurze frage steht da unten überhaupt
jemand also redet einfach mit sich
selbst und mit wem redet er riet ob ich
helfen heute dach und schreibt irgendwie
sollen die gegen ich bin der bar wo ihr
könnt nichts gegen machen stehe ich da
überhaupt jemand personal trainer will
mal sagen die haut wird dominiert das
gesamte ghetto bisschen angst und
schrecken
das ist ein typ mir weil er hat drei
silvesterraketen
[Musik]
ok existieren hier sehen wir jetzt drei
junge männer die tatsächlichen köln
bambus t shirt an haben also #tatort
wieso heißt steige seid ihr damit auf
twitter unterwegs oder auf instagram
soll sich die die community der köln war
wurster organisieren können marita otte
sind sind das vielleicht die richtigen
köln bambus und der auf dem dach tut mir
so weit bei dem habe ich keinen köln bus
t shirt gesehen geisteskrank alter was
für ein wahnsinniger wie die soll die
polizei dann noch was machen
wie soll die bundeswehr noch was machen
so deutschland ist verloren denn der
will dann kann er das ganze land
regieren er ist bereit
er ist bereit heute las für das vergehen
ps bereit knaller von einem dach zu
werfen und es ist nicht mal silvester
absolut der psychopath muss man noch
nicht so krass feiern oder ich verstehe
das nicht wieso wieso haben die hälfte
köln war bus t shirts an also ich muss
sagen wir nicht ganz sicher was es damit
auf sich hat aber auch diese diskussion
der so haarsträubend dummheit wenn ich
jemanden sehen würde der knaller vom
dach schmeißt würde ich mich mit
niemanden darüber diskutieren ob der
enns krasses ich finde einfach denken
okay dessen spaß
ich gehe weiter
also der tipp gibt ihm können sie noch
so ein bisschen vorsprung und gibt ihm
noch mehr kredit als er eigentlich
verdient hat und sagt ja okay das ist
schon cool was er nicht ist aber an
goalie mit einem komischen schal um den
mund ab dem herbst so ja er ist das
schon cool aber mehr auch nicht mal also
nur cool die ja ich will
[Musik]
paul sommer spenst du kommen sofort
darunter mittlerweile mehr geschädigt
das gehirn hat jetzt ein echter über das
anderes erwartet bevor gestellt war der
hesse hat so in der routine darin dass
er einfach alles
liga unter verdacht knaller raketen
kommt so seine mutter
paul was machst du da drin ist weil sie
auch noch runter
es ist im unterricht was machst du denn
je sie soll was ich mache wird
du kommst jetzt sofort hierher und
wieder rein mama mama ich terrorisiert
gerade die start
mama echt jetzt nicht kannst du dich
einmal ein mir mein hobby lassen ich bin
hat dabei leute zu unterdrücken ok angst
und schrecken verbreiten
barroso es sind jetzt noch ein böller an
das ding ja sag mal hast du hast ja
schon so musste der vogel
das ist schuhe
ok also wir sehen heute paul dieser
junge der stadt die bilder vom dach
schmeißt hat auf jeden fall auch ein
gangster hintergrund okay er kommt aus
krassen familienverhältnissen quasi
direkt aus der wird seine mutter ist
einfach schuldirektorin also paul ich
will deinen traum nicht zerstören so und
bist auf jeden fall auch köln bardot
aber wenn deine mutter schuldirektorin
ist weiß nicht wird es glaube ich
relativ schwer mit der gangster karriere
wir müssen auch so eine klasse aktion
starten nicht dass er sonst die eigene
clique eröffnet heute leider keiner
wurst das ist meine sorge sein
ich hab doch schon planen also
aufklärung geht weiter leute scheinbar
sind das die kölner bewusst leute die da
unten standen und sie haben den bisher
insgesamt neun mal vorbestraften und
ganze 0 x inhaftierten anführer der sich
natürlich als anführer der köln barfuß
und damit quasi höchstes tier in köln
eigentlich auch in ganz deutschland
natürlich sehr sicher ist dass er die
sache lösen wird nicht mehr sehr
gespannt ich hab keinen bock hier auf
die scheiße wiesen umgezogen ich bin ja
auf einer karte schule und alles kommt
das ja noch sehen doch bestehe nicht
kann
beim paul also ich werde nicht wieder
zwischen gretchen fernlicht und die
stimmung unterziehen
aber die frau mit der du gerade das das
ist deine mutter also die zeit für alles
in seinem leben und das ist auch noch
die direktorin an der schule an der du
bist also wenn eine person in deinem
leben die ich so richtig kann dann ist
sie ist der neue motor kann koch daraus
jetzt gäste zu uns ins zeug
ich muss wirklich sagen das ist auf
jeden fall einer der traurigen anblick
nicht in meinem leben bisher gesehen
habe wie sie diesen typen davon
überzeugen ihre clique reinzukommen und
dann zugestellt sind es gerade einmal
was genau aber der größte war wo wir
noch ich nach der aktion ist nach us
leute alter die spannung steigt der
anführer der kölner muss konfrontiert
paul also ich muss sagen es wird auf
jeden fall bei mir zu akutem
gehirnzellen tod dass ich allein schon
leute darüber reden höre ja darüber
streiten höhere wäre der grösste babo
ist dieses video wurde 2018 hochgeladen
23 etwa 2018 wer hat 2018 noch ernsthaft
das wort bar benutzt also eher kalt auf
jeden fall man ja das wird sofort
eingesteckt ist es dein ernst gerade ein
t shirt bekommen wo hashtag köln was
draufsteht ok hashtag wir sind nicht auf
fakten twitter okay das ist das echte
leben und auch im echten leben keine
steckt und ich krieg wirklich augenkrebs
felice di lucia gehe wer auch immer das
design hat hat vorher noch kein t shirt
design soviel kann man schon mal sagen
wohl eher so alter geisteskrank das
musste jetzt muss ich ja wohl
wir sehen heute pauls gangster niveau
erreicht an diesem punkt den absoluten
ziemlich okay mehr gangster kann man
nicht sein
selbst 50 cent ist ein scheiß dagegen
okay er nimmt das kölner muss schnell an
ist dabei auf einen member in der gegner
was passiert als nächstes seine mutter
kommt und bringt ihm sein pausenbrot in
der medienwelt als 2000 jahre später
schlüssel müssen uns also die tatsache
dass er selbst auf seine absolute nette
familie kommt ist ja klar seine mutter
hat auch die klassische ghetto mutter
karriere hat studiert hat dann doktor
gemacht und ins schulleiterin geworden
ist einfach und stories die kennt man
nicht anders das wird auf jeden fall aus
zogen sich verliert ein schlüssel für
die schule und will das büro seiner
eigenen mutter verwüsten kamera läuft ja
alles aloe zimmer rast ein richtiger
kölner warum macht und applaus für
bauleute paul beweist mal wieder dass
sie einfach nicht nur im gangster ist
dann auch eine absolute intelligenz bist
hier berichtete das büro seiner eigenen
mutter ein beschädigtes eigentum seine
eigene mutter und schmiert dann in das
büro von der frau die ihn auf die welt
gebracht hat hashtag köln bis ans
fenster also paul ich musste wirklich
sagen du bist wirklich absolut restlos
behindert wirken dass die ganze sache
eines mit dem leute und zwar wenn ihr
aus einem guten elternhaus kommt eure
mutter ist zum beispiel die rektorin an
der örtlichen schule dann tut der welt
einen gefallen und macht nicht auf
gangster in diesem sinne das was von
diesem weg die leute hier kritisiere und
vorgeschlagen das video könnte man kann
abonnieren dank fürs zuschauen nicht
größere augen